Sen beni tanımayanlar için benim adım
Deniz Dülgeroğlu Genelgesi'nin bu
konuşmalara çağırıyor Bunun sebebi
kariyerimin ilginç görüşlere sahip
olması Ben Ortaokulu bir şey bıraktı
okumuştum genelde bu arkadaşlar mezun
olanlar belli meslekleri tercih ederler
Ya böyle işte şarkı falan gibi böyle
havalı çizgide pek çok insan sahibini
sanat gibi alanlarda Ergün elinden ya da
işte böyle bir şirketin başına geçerler
bir şekilde tercih ettim iki fakültede
Herkes şaşırmış çıkıyor bak kız gelmedi
sebebi Çünkü annemin bana eğer işte
tiyatrocu olursan aç kalırsın Türkiye'de
çatı görmek için nefis kokarak
yazıyorsunuz biz de işte o zaman Yargıcı
başka meslek yemiştir iç mimarlık öpeyim
anne dediğimde aos2 çevresine bizim
sosis çevremizi kaç kalıyorsun demesiydi
endüstriyel tasarım uzunluk İman ne
demiştim o zamanlar yükselen bir meslek
fiyatı bir meslek Hani bir
bu Fanta sahibi böyle ilginç şeyler
yapayım yaratıcılığını o anlamda
demiştim Annem ama dedi o mesleğin ne
olacağı belli değil dedi bir tane
akrabamız vardı onu örnekler olur
bakmıyorsun ama sonra gidip İnşaat
Mühendisliği okumuştu İnşaat
mühendisiyle Türkiye inşaatlar durduğu
için yapma da baksa ticareti ne girdi
amaçlıdır bak dedim bugün arttırdım yani
istemiyorsan dedi o işi yapma Ben bu
şekilde Annem de çekim olduğu için
herhalde dedim Yani bir şekilde olmak
mantıklı kendim seçtiğimiz zannederek
bir şekilde seçtim Aslında annem diğer
bütün mesleklerin üstünü kapattığı için
yardımcı seçenekli bana o kalmış Yani
ben de Kendim istediğim zannederek
seçtim ama bir şekilde yine birlikte
gelmişti burada Marmara Üniversitesi'nde
rekor Gül puanla ama her anından nefret
ettim üniversite beş senelik de fakülte
Ben gelirsem de bitirdim bunu bir
senesine annem okula gitmediğimi
anlamasın diye odamdaki görme Dolabın
içinde saklanarak geçirdim Her gün 5
saat yakın Dolabın içinde Nefes almadan
duruyordu
Evet Ee sonra okul bittikten sonra ya
muayene açacaksın ya Bir şey yapacak ya
bir şekilde artık bir şekilde olman
gerekiyordu O kadar nefret ediyorum ki
açmak için ne yapabilirim diye
düşünürken istedim gidip bir doktor
yapayım ben ve çene cerrahisi alanında
doktora yaptım Çene Cerrahisi seçmek
gerçekten yani Kek olupta yürüyen bir
seçim oldu çünkü ben dünyanın en
konuşmayı sever insanıyım cerrahisinde
hastalarımızda kalmış olduğu için
Genesis altında makineye bağlısın dıt
dıt bu sesi duyarak böyle saatlerce
hastamıza Ne çalışıyorsunuz kimseyle
konuşamıyorsun en fazla hemşireye eşler
vermişler falan gibi muhabbet leriniz
oluyor Ben o yüzden bıraktım ve 26
yaşında Herkes bana deli misin derken
stajyer olarak bir reklam ajansında
girdim ve reklam yazarlığına başladım ve
geçen seneye kadar çok 35 yaşındayım ben
34 yaşına kadar 8 Sn reklam yazarlığı
yaptım
bu ve ondan sonra geçen sene artık
reklam ajanslarında ki yoğun tempoya ve
şu an aramızda reklam sektörüne girdi
Yok bir şey söylemeye daha fazla
dayanamadım hastaneye kaldırıldım bir
gecede sakinleştirici olup ve hala
uyuyamadım bir hale gelmiştir ve en
sonunda erkek kardeşiz dedik ki yani
Böyle devam edersen öleceksin seçim
senin bırakmak zorunda kaldım bu sefer
de ve Neyse ki bir yandan da yaptığım
bir pop kestim vardır merdiven atıştırıp
üstünde ve post gelsin yavaş yavaş
büyümeye başlamıştı O yüzden de ajanstan
istifa edip kestim e nasıl reklam
olabilir diye düşünmeye başladım
reklamda içerikler yapmaya başladım web
İnstagram hesabımı bugün hecesi büyüttüm
geçen sene bu zamanlar sadece kendi
arkadaşlarını takip ederken 60 binin
üzerinde insan takip ediyordu büyümeye
devam ediyorum Bütün bunları niye
anlattım Türkiye'de Bence en çok annem
o duyduğum şey işte bölümünü seçerken
çok iyi bir bölüm seç o bölümüne
kaderini belirleyecek Hep Bize öğretilen
şey bu oluyor Sen çok eskiden
söylediysem memur olarak devlete girerdi
Ondan sonra artık ölene kadar orada
emekliliğin alana kadar memuru kalıcı
olarak hayata geçirdi çektirmesi olurdu
bir insanım bugün ama artık Hayat o
kadar hızlı değişiyor ki yani siz de
değişiyorsun onun içinde ve biz sizin 17
yaşınızda Diş Hekimi olma kararını veren
Deniz Dülgeroğlu Bugün 35 yaşında ayrı
hissetmiyor Ama annemizi babamızı
mantığına göre hala gibi olması lazım
Çünkü bu dengesizlik bir bu varmış
saflıktır Bu geleceğini riske atmaktır
bana hep bu korku öğretildiği içinden
bütün bu kadar değişikliğin çok
korkuyordum özeti ilkine bir şey
kimliğini bak reklamcı ona karar verin
aldığımda bütün çevrem bana hani ah
nasıl yaptı bunu kendisi sanki intihar
etmiş incesine böyle abi seni bugün
geleceğim oldu kızım diye en çok
korkarak Bak benden daha çok kokla Ben
de çok korkuttular ama sonra
Bu ikinci kez karaya değiştirdim
reklamcılıktan insan Çelik Şimdi de çok
belli olmuş Nestle gittiğinde insanlar
bana yine aynı yapma sırasında dedim ki
Tamam ben birisine uçurumdan atladım
dizisinde bir kimseyi korkutmasın izin
vermeyeceğim başına gördüm bir şekilde
reklamcılar geçmek bir çok mutlu etmişti
eklemde demek böyle çok çok çok tatlısın
et dediğinizde mutluluk olarak dosyamız
konuşacak yükseliyor O yüzden bir yandan
yaşlanma korkusu varken hayatımın bir
sağlıkçı iyi biliyor musun hiçbir şey
teselli ediyor Hiçbir şekilde okuduğun
mesleği yapmak sana değil misin Senin
kaderini belirleme olmuş bir şekilde
dikme mu elimden de asıl Doktorunuz
geçiyorum ben şimdi seni zorda kalsam
yapabileceğim bitmiştir Hala
yapabiliyorum yapmamız gerekmekte
özelliği içinde keza gerekmişti ve 26
yaşında ters olarak girmem içinde bir
engel yokmuş 34 yaşında ilk nasıl olmak
istediği engel yokmuş Çünkü mesela
içinde şey diyorlar 18 yaş çocuklar
yapabilir Onun dışında kimsenin ne
yaptın yaşlı kadını
bu falan diye düşündüm hiç öyle bir şey
yokmuş eğer alacak iyi bir kendi varsa
arkasını bilmiyormuş o yüzden yani ben
şeye şimdi bakıyorum da hani ben yine
iyice sert etmiştim gözünü kararmıştı bu
kararları almışım Ama eminim bir
yerlerde bir çok insan içinde kendi
fotoğrafımı görmesin hemen yapabilecek
mi bilmesine rağmen başka insanlar
tarafından korkutuldu için bu şifalı
böyledir bunu okudun yapacaksın dendiği
için işte senin Cinsiyetin kadın ne
bileyim yeşil şu işte senin lisan yetmez
İngilizcem kötü falan gibi bir sürü
toplumumuzda böyle şeyler koyduğu için
yani bizde onların hiç sorgulamayı bile
aklı demiyoruz yani bu kadar insan
herhalde bir şey bilmiyor diyoruz Bazen
o kadar hiçbir şey bilmiyor gerçekten
bir şey bilmiyorlar be Hani bu sevdiğim
insanlar Ali Hadi benim annem babam
Yaşlı yani Robert Koleji ki oldu akıllı
zeki arkadaşlar da bir insanlar benden
çok Korkular Ben dişçiye bırakırken yani
şimdi ama hepsi diyebilirler
arkadaşlarına yok Bir Kız Vardı bizim
arkadaş bıraktı
bu eserler çıkacak bir tane örneği var o
yüzden bazen eğer gittiğimiz yolda
önemli Daha önce çıkmamışsa o iş hani
bunun bir anlamı Evet belki olabilir
Bunu yapmak derecede çok aptalca O
yüzden hiç kimse yapmadı ama belki
ikinci bir anlamda Şu olabilir Daha önce
hiç kimse buna cesaret edememiş harbi
bir kişi şarkısı yani o yoldaki Belki
ilk bir yapın olduğu için çok kıymetli
bir Hani alana sahip oldukları şey
derler ya burada zamanında gıda arazi
alanı ödemedik yani Belki bizi takip
etmiş olacaksınız mesajını Benim Hikayem
Ben orijinal yapıyor reklam sektöründe
paylaşmamız lazım Çünkü bu işi bırakıp
da gelen başka köpekleri yoksa etrafta
Yani insanlar genelde böyle işte
ekonomik başka kimse yoktu o yüzden hani
26 yaşında Biz tercih olarak zorluk
çekebilecek kendi çünkü dedi diye her
gittiğinde insan haberle tanışmayı
istedi O yüzden belki de bu eklemler
sizin hikayenizde olabilir sizi böyle
üzerinde spot ışıkları
O hep olacak birşeyde dönüşebilir hani
şey diyorlar buna affetmeyeceğim bu
kadar değişikliğinin reklamcılıkla
derler gerçekten çok da bıraktım var
şimdi göstermiş olduğun birisiyle
olmayabilir bir daha bir daha
değiştirebilirsin Bugün kendi postersiz
diyorum yarın ne yapacağımı bilmiyorum
Ama şundan dolayı memnun kendi kendime
artık şunu biliyorum Eskiden böyle
sürekli aşırı fazla akrep yaşadım
gelecekte ne olacak diye ve yani bekle
avcılık gibi bir meslekte bile yani
Gelecek kaygısı beni seviyordun çok şeyi
düşünüyorum yani beş Kırkından Sonra
model şans gitmek o kadar yolu var ki 40
yaşında insan göremiyorum Göremezsin
zaten sabaha kadar nasıl olsa çocuğa
yoksa zaten uykusuzluk anlamında sabah
dörde kadar çalışmadım çalışmadım ne
yapacağım ne yapacağım canım Yani soğuk
mu biliyor musunuz reklamcı bile değilim
hayatımı geçirdi şimdi bu mesleği
yapıyorum şimdi mesaj hiçbir gelecek
herhalde şimdi şunu düşünüyorum İyi
Konseyi bir reklamcılıktan bir şey da
faşist bir dünya
Ya ben 60 yaşında ilk onu hiç görmedim
elli yaşında gelmedi Beni Bak sen 45 de
falan oyuncuları biraz kenardan kenardan
yapıyor de beklerim son kullanma
tarihine çok kaldı diye düşünüyorum ama
eskiden olduğu gibi korkuyorum çıkış
anne olacağını bilmiyorum al bir şey
olacak Eğer Siz kafanıza Hani her türlü
çözüm bulmaya öğretirseniz bir şekilde
yolunu bulabilecek öğretirseniz artık
anksiyeten Bakanlığı'nda bazı motif diye
düşünüyorum ben hiçbir şey yapmıyorum ya
çünkü benim kendi korumak için elbise
etmeye çok alışmıştı endişe edip çözüm
bulmam lazım olabilir hepsine göre
hesaplayıp ona göre bir yol çizmem lazım
diye ama şimdi artık şöyle kendimiz şey
dert etmiyorum yani sıkıntıya
çeviriyorum bir şekilde bir şeyler
oluyor Yollar bulunuyor Ve bu yolla
hiçbir şekilde de hani daha önceden size
öğretilmiş dümdüz böyle ana yolları
olmak zorunda değil Belki sizi annenizin
olmasın İşte korktu karanlık oralarda
sokak lambası yanmıyor girmediği yollara
çizgiporno bir sokak lambaları açarsınız
bir anda orada birlikte sizden göre bir
açar üstüne bir tane
bu Kahvedekiler olsun Yakışır herkese
gelmek gibi Sokak alır O yüzden bence
Hadi demek istediğim şey şu an Siz
hayatınızda hangi noktasında sunuz
aklından neler geçiyor gelecek emzirenin
ev yani bana bu güzeldi çünkü para
kazandıran meslekler belli görüntülerde
Ben şunu anladım Eğer siz sevmiyorsunuz
içinizden gelmiyor zaten o iş o kadar
kırk yapıyorsunuz ki şekilde para
kazanamazsınız boşta ama işlemesini
Annemin bana izin vermedik çaycılık işi
Eğer izin vermiş olsaydı belki de onu o
kadar sevdiğim için o kadar kendi
kendime onu alacaktım o kadar güzel
fikirler bulacaktım o kadar öyle
çıkacaktı Bak hiç kimse kazanmadı bir
para kazanıyor olacaksın yani belası
diyeceğim şu an maddi açıdan da hiçbir
sıkıntı da çektiğimi söyleyemem maddi
anlamda kodlayıcı olmadı Manevi anlamda
hiç olmadı yani hepsi gidiyorum Bugün
sabah kalksana Bütün bunların Hepsi
rüyaymış dönmeye hala
E herhalde Dükkanı ya çatlarım Yani
insan istemediği dünyadan çıkıp işte bir
şeyler yaşamaya başlayınca Eskiden
istemediği şeyi yapmadan her güne kadar
büyük işkence olduğunu anlıyor Benim zor
dedim aşağı yukarı böyle bir çok
teşekkür ederim o zaman zaman
ayırdığınız için